joining me now is congressman jim banks
chairman of the republican study
committee who's uh calling attention to
all this congressman you've been a real
champion and kind of highlighting this
and the exorbitancy there's i mean it's
just unbelievable it's just line after
line of this give us some more examples
of some of the
overspending that's in this bill
yeah jason when you were in congress
they had the affordable care act which
we all know led to uh
less access and more expensive health
care now we have the inflation reduction
act if they called it what it really is
which is the green new deal this really
is the the radical climate change agenda
of the democrat party
they would get laughed out of the room
so what did they do they gave it a fake
name the inflation reduction act there
are tons of subsidies for wealthy people
who buy solar panels of course you've
all heard about the 87 000 new irs
agents that are being funded in this
bill which by the way are being tasked
with going out and finding over a
hundred billion dollars in revenue from
working class americans so
87 000 irs agents notre dame's football
stadium couldn't hold all of those new
irs agents so the more you dig into this
bill the more you realize how much the
democrat party is lying to you and i
believe the american people have caught
on to this and november will be a
testament to that but the more the more
layers you peel back on this bill you
realize that it does the exact opposite
of what they tell you it's going to do
well
well let's listen to speaker nancy
pelosi describe what's in the bill
in that bill he has 60 billion dollars
for diversity as we meet the challenge
of the climate crisis it's about
inclusion it's about investing in our
children our future our education
in research it's about doing so in a way
that is respectable of a great diversity
of views
i didn't hear a word about inflation
well now now they're now they're coming
clean after they passed the bill after
after after president buying it biden
signed it into law nancy pelosi is
telling you actually she's telling you
the truth in this case that doesn't have
anything to do with inflation jason
there are massive tax increases on
working-class americans in this bill
there there are actually tax increases
on manufacturing businesses i represent
the district in america has that has the
most manufacturing jobs per capita and
under president trump we return manufact
good paying manufacturing jobs back to
america more than ever before so now
we're getting now with the democrats in
charge we're going to tax those jobs out
of existence this this this bill is
dangerous it's radical and it's going to
hurt working-class americans and people
are waking up to it and there's going to
be hell to pay on election day
okay real quickly here i want to i want
to mention the the leftists at axios
they're now arguing that climate change
is the culprit that is causing inflation
extreme weather worsened by climate
change is a hidden cause of inflation
heavy rainfall flooding heat waves and
droughts erode agriculture
infrastructure and workers abilities to
stay on the job all of which lead to
supply chain breakdowns and worker
shortages
i thought it was putin who was behind
this these price increases but evidently
now it's climate change and
that's why this is going to reduce
inflation somehow
it's insanity again it's the it's the
policies of the democrat party no matter
what they call it it's their policies
their their massive spending agenda
their radical climate change green new
deal agenda that's caused inflation the
american people have caught on to it
they don't need to be educated they get
it and i i really do believe election
day is going to prove it
yeah i think the 1.5 billion dollars for
planting trees in urban areas i just
we this country cannot keep doing that
sort of garbage you just really can't
congressman banks thank you so much for
joining us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else